yo yo hey I might be young but I might
change your mind too you're way too
young to change my mind my brother no I
know I have a lot of knowledge but not
enough what do you mean you need you
need you need a lot more time to be able
to change my mind bro I already got
enough time you don't got enough time
all right give me your give me your best
argument let me hear it wait what do you
want to talk about you Jus is God yeah
Jesus Is God let me see let's go to Mark
okay Mark
1534 nice nice nice you're already
starting off good my God my God why are
you forsaken me nice so so if Jesus Is
God right and just just imagine if you
were God right
uh-huh and you say if you if you're God
right and you say oh God oh God forsake
me if I be God and have another God that
that's that's probably a mistake right
if you have another God sure but this is
if I'm if I'm God do do I have another
God n if you're God bro you don't have
another God outside of yourself but but
the Bible disagree no I would say the
Bible agrees with me no but who whose
word is better the word of Jesus or the
word of your I'll say the word of Jesus
is excellent my brother see he disagree
with you so can I can I can I show you
now the words of Jesus I show you so let
me ask you this I asked I asked the
brother before I'm going ask you this
well actually I'm going ask you a
different question who can forgive sins
Allah right so if someone says that
they're the one who forgives sins then
they're claiming to be Allah right which
which will be blasphemy which would be
blasphemy
right okay all right so in Mark since
since you quoted Mark I'm going to stay
in Mark okay all in Mark chapter 2 so
before we get to chapter 15 into the
crucifixion let's we go to chapter two
it says this um or Jesus heals a
paralytic and it says
from Allah nope it doesn't say that yes
it said in the Quran well this isn't the
Quran this is the
Bible this is the words of Jesus not the
Quran Quran is not the words of Jesus so
it says here and they came bringing to
him a paralytic somebody who was
paralyzed carried by four men and when
they could not get near him because of
the crowd they removed the roof above
him and when they had made an opening
they let down the bed on which the
paralytic lay and when Jesus saw their
faith he said to the paralytic
son your sins are forgiven now some of
the scribes are sitting there
questioning in their hearts why does
this man speak like that he is
blaspheming who can forgive sins but God
Alone see the Pharisees agree with you
that only God can forgive sins I agree
with you too and immediately Jesus
perceiving in his Spirit what they thus
questioned within themselves so Jesus
was able to read their minds and knew
what they were thinking he said to them
why do you question these things in your
hearts which is easier to say to the
paralytic your sins are forgiven or to
say rise take up your bed and walk he
says but that you may know that the son
of man has Authority on Earth to forgive
sins he said to the paralytic I say to
you rise pick up your bed and go home
and he rose and immediately picked up
his bed and went out before them all so
that they were all amazed and glorified
God saying we never saw anything like
this all right I you see you see how
Jesus says he has the authority to
forgive sins yeah there's different
answer so um so Jesus was sinless right
he he was God that's that's you that's
what you guys saying right he can only
forgive sins if he's God all right so if
Jesus was sinless and God then why did
he lie to people hold on why are you
going somewhere else what does it got to
do with anything no no no no you you
literally said that Jesus can forgive
but why does he lie why does Jesus lie
where where does he lie here did he lie
and say did he lie about this man sins
being forgiven what I'm g go I'm G just
get the
verse see that see Hal Hal Gojo we're
not going anywhere else we got to focus
here I don't read the I don't read the
Bible but I just
IJ relax relax bro relax calm down I
know you don't read the Bible this is
why I said you don't have enough
knowledge to change my mind yet I do I I
do Paul look wait wait forget Paul deal
it with this Jesus says that he has
authority to forgive sins and is even
forgiving sins and he's claiming to be
God
right I I didn't hear you what yes yes
okay so all the way in Mark 2 we have
Jesus showing that he's God now let's
stick with Mark 2 let me ask you another
question who is the owner and the
creator of the Sabbath Allah all right
so who's the lord of the Sabbath then
Allah very good now watch what Jesus
says here Jesus
says the Sabbath was made for man not
man for the Sabbath so the son of man is
Lord even of the Sabbath Jesus says that
he's lord of the Sabbath so if only
Allah is Lord of the Sabbath and Jesus
says he's the lord of the Sabbath then
Jesus is claiming to be God right well
Allah claims to be God too I I know so
we have both here an example another
example where Jesus claims to be God
right in Mark yeah all right so this is
two two places now where Jesus shows
that he himself is God and this is only
in Chapter 2 so before you even get to
chapter 15 where he's on the cross and
he cries out to his father he
establishes that he himself is God so
now what do we do here what do we do
with Jesus Jesus who claims to be God
and even shows that he's God by
forgiving sins being lord of the Sabbath
right he shows that he's God what how do
we reconcile him also saying that the
father is his God how do we reconcile
this without falling into polytheism is
the question and it's as simple as this
bro you listening yeah okay in the Old
Testament Jeremiah 32:27 this is what it
says it says that God is the God of All
Flesh God is the God of All Flesh so we
also have I have a I have a question so
was the Old Testament was made by old
people uh like Greek people right Greek
Hebrew and Hebrew they spoke Hebrew and
some of them were Greek too so no they
wasn't yeah some of them were Greek too
so in in the Old Testament in the Old
Testament back they used to use Allah
name as God bro Allah Allah Gojo they
were not Greek man they were Hebrew
there was bunch of them Greek that
okay yeah see that's that's why I say
that you know it's not um you're not
you're not ready you're not you're not
listening to me too okay well you have a
good day man you have a good day study
some more maybe we we'll talk when you
grow up a little bit you but you're
literally running away that's all right
though you're right you're right you're
right you did a great job today yes you
did a great
job oh man these children